bonjour dès qu'on approche des remparts
de saint malo où nous allons flâner dès
qu'on s'apprête à pénétrer intra muros
on comprend la fascination que cette
ville a exercé sur les poètes les
écrivains et les historiens bien sûr
mais le livre dont je me suis le plus
servi c'est celui d'un ami c'est celui
d'un comédien poète lui aussi c'est
daniel gélin daniel gélin est venu ici
il avait dix ans et comme beaucoup de
visiteurs il ressent toujours la même
impression impression dit il
indéfinissable sensation d'un univers
clos habité et comme hanté hanté par
quoi et bien par le souvenir de grands
découvreurs et de grands corsaires et la
bourdonnais quartier surcouf
duguay-trouin stands à lui est resté
deux jours dans cette ville et il en est
ressorti avec la sensation d'avoir été
dans une prison alors il aurait dû
s'inspirer de l'esprit de chateaubriand
qui lui respirer l'air du large
[Musique]
allez
et
[Musique]
ok
le
ah les tempêtes malouines le calme aussi
de la mer les îles bretonnes
et bien tout ça convient très bien la
guitare de dan ar braz que nous
retrouvons camper à l'univers justement
la brasserie la plus célèbre de sa mère
[Musique]
et
m
oh
on
[Musique]
non
et
dumont
le
[Musique]
il
dan ar braz
je suis content de te rencontrer il ya
dix ans qu'on s'est vus et tu as fait 10
compact au moins depuis que je t'ai vu
tu chantes tu chantes beaucoup en
anglais tu chantes aussi en français tu
vas chanter des chansons de xavier grall
qui a fait un compact là dessus mais de
plus en plus c'est l'instrument que tu
as envie de cultiver mais je me suis
jamais considéré comme un chanteur comme
d'autres font leur première le premier
instrument c'est la voix moi je les
utilise quand quand bon me semble
quand quelque chose me quelque chose est
à dire par les mots et j'ai d'ailleurs
plus souvent chanté en anglais qu'en
français
vu que je travaille dans les pays où
c'est la langue est utilisé pour que tu
enregistres d'ailleurs du côté d'oxford
dans l'angle en angleterre ou chez des
copains dans un petit village et mais je
me dirige c'est vrai de plus en plus à
la musique instrumentale un langage
universel
je le savais j'ai oublié nanar braz
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
daniel legrand d'aller plus nombreuses
en breton ça veut dire quelque chose de
grand c'est pas de ma faute agenaise non
écoute je n'ai pas choisi c'est quelque
chose de grand j'ai du mal à dire que tu
joue de la musique instinctive parce que
les traîtres est composée elle est très
large et très lié beaucoup d'instruments
etc mais pourtant tu connais pas le
solfège
non je connais strictement rien mais
dont je joue das jeu si je joue
d'instinct je joue je fais de la
peinture j'ai l'impression plus que de
la musique j'aime bien des couleurs
j'essaye de superposer différentes
couleurs musicales pour en faire un
tableau
et d'ailleurs ça me pose un problème
parfois sur scène lorsque dans une
certaine mesure sur scène on peut pas
tous les soirs et peintre ne va pas
refaire un tableau chaque fois chaque
soir donc il fait le tableau il est
exposé il est reproduit comme un disque
est reproduit en compactant cassettes et
je me fait je serais mieux dans cette
situation d'être d'être plus derrière ma
musique me mettre devant offert est
resté derrière elle qu'elle soit
diffusée par tous les moyens de
diffusion possible qui existent de par
le monde mais que je reste plus derrière
que ce soit elle qui parle tout seul
la bretagne c'est ma terre
la bretagne comment il le vit pour toi
aujourd'hui elle vit elle existe avec sa
différence à ce que je dis aux gens il
faut qu'ils acceptent cette différence
ils n'acceptent pas on s'en sortira
jamais aimé avoir sa différence et
accepter celle des autres aussi des
projets beaucoup le plus près beaucoup
de musique instrumentale en tout cas
merci dan ar braz et ta musique va nous
accompagner tout au long de ce parcours
à saint malo avec bonté des deux
derniers compacts qui sont les îles de
la mémoire et rêve de siam
[Musique]
notre ami manhwa daniel gélin à 18 en
1939 à saint malo écrit-il nous
finissions nos journées au bar de
l'univers
hanté par tous les grand bourlingueur
nous aimions le jazz les surprises
parties étaient nombreuses et
parfaitement folle comme partout cet été
là en france nous dansions et nous
chantions sur un volcan
j'ai un ou 2 44 à paris au gaumont
palace
il va voir le dictateur de chaplin et ya
les actualités et qu'est ce qu'il voit
aux actualités des images bouleversantes
la caméra après avoir filmé la porte
saint-vincent honte intacte montre à ma
ville vaste amas de ruines fumantes pan
de mur fantomatique vision implacable
est stupéfiante qui me fit éclater en
sanglots sans retenue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quelques années plus tard daniel gélin
rencontres au cours d'une soirée à
hollywood
j jean stewards à propos d'un film
d'hitchcock il rencontre le metteur en
scène
joshua logan joshua logan lui demande
ses metteurs en scène de bus stop si
vous souvenez ou de du film avec marlon
brando qui s'appelait sayonara alors
logan lui demande vous êtes d'où vous
jenna répond je suis de saint malo à
vous êtes de saint malo eh bien figurez
vous que ce que vous avez vu ou aux
actualités
moi je l' ai vécu parce que j'étais
officier dans l'artillerie américaine et
je bombardaient la ville de paramé et
quand je suis entré dans les ruines de
saint malo mais j'en ai pleuré vol
[Musique]
je vais rencontrer maintenant philippe
poutou qui est le conservateur des
musées de saint malo alors évidemment il
connaît très bien si journée de
bombardements de destruction de la ville
de saint malo mais il connaît surtout la
période exemplaire de la reconstruction
[Musique]
oui
philippe bonjour bonjour je vous êtes de
conservateur de musée de cette ville et
nous sommes ici devant un trophée un
trophée qui a coûté beaucoup alors c'est
le drapeau nazi de la garnison de saint
malo il a été capturé
c'est très émouvant parce qu'elle est
non de ce qu'ils ont pris les américains
bien sûr nick de grazia junior à son
père nick de nadia saint malo france
capturé le 8 août 44 citadelle six ans
un prisonnier puis lé nom de ses copains
de new york de buffalo de chicago qui
participait à l'assaut mais qu'est ce
que ça a coûté en vies humaines et en
destructions de saint malo destruction
puisque en fait c'est le patrimoine
historique dite ville qui a disparu en
l'espace d'une semaine 6 mois d'août 44
par y ait eu des feux croisés les
allemands tirait les américains tiraient
mais les américains ont fait plus de
dégâts csu l'a retiré américaine peut
être surprise par ses remparts de vauban
s'est trouvé face à une citadelle que
''c'était qui est trop devenu saint malo
depuis l'occupation
alors justement ce qui est formidable
c'est tout le monde de dire vous allez
voir ça tout le monde dit ça je sais une
alim la reconstruction de saint malo a
été exemplaire
et bien si on voulait que ça malheureux
viveo redevienne ce qu'elle avait été
dans les années d'avant la guerre un
centre touristique centre de ville très
vivant et chargé d'histoire qu'aux
charges simplement
il fallait donc re bâtir la ville dans
ses limites traditionnelles alors il a
fallu d'abord des mines et il a fallu il
a fallu des vidéos patron ou mais
surtout démonter les façades numéroter
les matériaux à 6 rue allendé ruth oui
préparer l'assiette des nouvelles villes
avec tous les équipements et puis il
refaire des plans parce qu'il n'y avait
pas de relevé de la convention c'est ça
on est parti de ruines qu'il a fallu
quelques fois numérotée faire de
photographies de rez de chaussée
imaginez une ville nouvelle tout en
étant finalement c'est fidèle à son
architecture ancienne et en modernisant
ce qu'il y avait à l'intérieur année il
fallait bien aussi un fan et modèles et
des intérieurs créer des perspectives un
peu plus élargie créer des et des
appartements plus nombreux parce que en
fait il fallait gagner en hauteur ce
qu'on perde en surface et oui il fait de
reloger 2000 personnes il fallait
reloger à l'époque la 7 à 8000 habitants
et 2000 logements étaient à reconstruire
sa jolie logement dans la cité à la fin
de la reconstruction manqué la flèche de
la cathédrale qui vise t sans doute
abattu par les allemands
on en est à peu près sûr et c'est alors
se terminer quand ce couronnement qui s
est fait très longtemps attentes puisque
terminé en 1971 il y a un peu plus de
vatan et saint malo est redevenu saint
malo à ce moment là merci monsieur but
[Musique]
l'activité économique de saint malo à
part la pêche bien entendu été longtemps
liées à l'exportation des textiles de
bretagne à base de lin aujourd'hui
disparu un autre secteur traditionnel a
fait vivre son port de commerce très
longtemps et le fait vivre encore
aujourd'hui c'est l'engrais langres été
retiré du merle qui est une algue
calcaire contient du fond des mers
aujourd'hui la troisième entreprise
d'ille-et-vilaine par son chiffre
d'affaires le groupe roullier dont le
président est aussi président de la
timac est le premier en france dans la
fertilisation les engraisse humeur elle
est bon avec beaucoup d'activités
diversifiées on va avoir monsieur
roulier qui est aussi le vice-président
de la chambre de commerce fort de saint
malo est un port qui fonctionne
relativement bien
bon alors on parle beaucoup dans la
presse locale autour de saint malo de
problèmes de jeu c'est pas d'une
faiblesse dans les transports on parle
il ferait que le tgv viennent il
faudrait que la quatre voies soient
terminés il faudrait bien on est en
train de le faire des roquettes et le
port pour faire venir les grands ferries
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous qui
est vice président de la chambre de
commerce
je pense que tout ça c'est très
important est que quand les malouins
prétendre qu'ils ont besoin d'un
déroctage je crois qu'ils ont raison le
déroctage c'est quelque chose de très
important parce que les bateaux vont
être de plus en plus gros nous allons
donc avoir de plus en plus de passagers
en provenance de l'angleterre ce qui est
essentiel pour une ville comme saint
malo qui est essentiellement tournée
vers le tourisme
j'espère aussi que nous aurons à la
faveur de ce déroutage la possibilité
d'avoir des trafics camion beaucoup plus
significatif parce que le touriste c'est
une chose mais l'industrie c'en est une
autre de leur déroute et on peut avoir
effectivement l'ambition de réussir et
le tourisme et l industrie et on va voir
enfin la route de nantes saint malo qui
va être terminé pratiquement dans
quelques mois avec l'appui du conseil
général conseil ne s'améliora nantes
saint malo et rennes saint malo
rennes saint malo a fortiori dans ce
qu'il fera qui fera que saint malo sera
la banlieue de rennes ou le contraire
qui fera que les rennais diront que
saint malo et la banlieue de rennes et
vous pouvez compter sur les malwares
qu'ils disent que rennes sera la
banlieue de saint malo oui mais bon on
est déjà engorgé un petit peu par le
tourisme ici il ya deux cent mille
personne n'était sur les plages c'est ça
ça va devenir lourd tous non non on peut
faire beaucoup plus beaucoup plus à
l'aise les une concentration très forte
sur quelques plages mais nous avons des
dizaines de kilomètres de plage dans les
jardins on peut mettre on peut doubler
le nombre de tourisme saint malo ggv le
tgv alors le tgv à la gare faut faire
des nous avons mal par la route
pharaonique
nous avons la route maintenant c'est
bien nous allons avoir le déroctage du
port je crois que si le tgv venait juste
que saint malo ce serait la solution
idéale
si vous voulez tout tout de suite quoi
on a tellement attendu
on a tellement entendu moi je trouve que
les malouins ont fait preuve d'une
patience extraordinaire extraordinaire
on l'attend sa troupe de plus de 30 ans
alors je crois qu'aujourd'hui ils ont
besoin mais ils ont besoin c'est normal
et un chômage énorme dans cette région
et il faut tout de suite
merci daniel oulié pour entrer dans le
port de saint malo tout commandant doit
s'en remettre aux pilotes du port car
l'accès du port de saint malo est assez
difficile il ya les écueils des rochers
il ya pour le démarrer il ya les cluses
a passé alors les pilotes du port font
entrer et sortir trois mille bateaux par
an ils sont d'une société privée mais
ils ont une mission de service public
m'a ils protègent les installations du
port en quittant bien les bateaux qui
protège aussi l'environnement en évitant
les échouages et nous allons rencontrer
avec valérie heurtel un de ces quatre
pilotes
il s'appelle par le reno et c'est un
ancien capitaine au long cours qui est
très content au fond de s'être fixé ici
il appelle du passé quand même un
concours pour devenir pilote du port
paul renoux est l'un des quatre pilotes
du port de saman ou jour et nuit ils
aident les cargos à entrer et sortir du
port manoeuvre délicate pour les bateaux
étrangers qui doit jouer avec les
courants les marais et les écueils ont
relâché un cargo là oui tout à fait nous
allons chercher un cargo allemand le
fera et talent qui est droit devant nous
et sur ce navire la cour
rentré au port de saint malo on va pas
une petite échelle oui une échelle de
corde alors c'est un navire de 120
mètres de long
qui est chargée qui à 7,70 de terrado
donc
pas tous très très haut
maximum je pense
dans la météo est mauvaise et
cela sous-entend que la mer aussi les
agités et quelquefois les mouvements le
long de la coque du navire sur lequel on
doit embarquer sont assez désordonné et
disons que
on risque peut-être notre ville une
dizaine de fois par an
comme le hockey
la marque apple sort jean allard pilote
à bord on prendra donc deux remorqueurs
et je souhaiterais le cancer devant et
le grand b derrière le pilote et le
conseiller technique du navire donc
juridiquement il n'y a pas de transfert
de commandement le commandant pardon
reste responsable sûr de son avenir
mais dans la pratique le commandant
qu'il est le pilote
effectuez l'entrée et la manoeuvre de
son navire je tente machine a pas
[Musique]
pourquoi y at il un pilote est remonté à
bord dans tous les ports nous devons
prendre un pilote c'est mieux qu'au
moins et puis si les lois qui nous
oblige à prendre un pilote sur leurs
atouts c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est plus
prudent
c'est en fait c'est un métier qui ne
connaît pas la routine les conditions de
marée ne sont jamais les mêmes les
conditions météorologiques ne sont
jamais les mêmes
les navires sont toujours différents
l'accueil est toujours chaleureux
c'était un peu prétentieuse que veut
dire mais nous avons un petit peu un
rôle d'ambassadeur puisque nous sommes
la première personne que les étrangers
rencontrent en arrivant au port saint
malo pourrait-elle devenir avec ces gros
ferries qui vont venir avec son tgv avec
ce à quatre voies une ville de congrès
permanente et bien elle en a les outils
par exemple comme le le palais des
congrès qu'on appelle ici le palais du
grand large
c'est sans doute pas suffisant mais déjà
se tiennent ici le festival de la bd
qu'on appelle quai des bulles à ses
bienfaits et le salon du livre d'
aventure qu'on appelle étonnants
voyageurs
mais l' aventure des livres est ici
permanente on pourrait la faire
commencer avec théophile briant qui fait
ici le promoteur de beaucoup d'écrivains
et de poètes et dont la veuve d'ailleurs
continue le maintien le flambeau avec
son association la tour du vent et l'
aventure des livres consacrés
exclusivement à la mer eh bien on la
trouve chez un petit libraire
d'apparence mais grands éditeurs
bertrand de kennitt on va le voir
[Applaudissements]
bonjour comment thales canada via alors
pour savoir d'où vous vient cette
passion pour la mer ou qui a été éditeur
exclusivement de livres sur la mer mais
oui exclusivement oui je crois plus ont
des petits plus il faut être exclusif
parce qu'on peut pas se disperser mais
je crois que aussi quand on a la passion
de la mer et la passion du livre les
deux se réunissent quelques fois dans
l'édition de la de livres de mer
pourquoi pas andy goode étiez pas du
tout destiné à sa non pas du tout non
j'ai une formation d'ingénieur donc vous
voyez ça ça rien à voir vous pouvez me
montrer le dernier bouquin que vous avez
édité fait c'est un pavé oui si vous
voulez vous muscler le matin ça fait 5
kilos et demi c'est en effet un ouvrage
sur saint malo c'est un petit peu
logique parce que c'est sur saint malo
et la mer et saint malo en plus au temps
de sa splendeur et s'étendant l'espagnol
qu'on va rencontrer d'ailleurs dans
cette émission
voilà ça s'appelle messieurs de saint
malo soir il ya déjà ces messieurs de
saint malo exact oui tout à fait qui est
un grand roman et vous en connaissez la
qualité qui est allé par berlin signaux
et vous savez qui avant donc entre
l'espagnol avant bernard signaux a pour
la première fois dit messieurs de saint
malo c'est elle ou 14 séries quand louis
xiv ayant des problèmes d'argent dit à
son ministre des finances mais demandez
donc à ces messieurs de sanglots de nous
prêter un petit peu d'argent parce
qu'ils ont nourris qu'ils avaient
beaucoup à l'époque vous éditez combien
de livres de mer parents parents bien
relativement peu parce que ça reste tout
à fait artisanale chez nous douze à
quatorze si vous voulez à peu près ce
qu'il fait à par mois environ
c'est ta maison si vous avez tout dans
votre beauté que vous avez des
porte-clés des cadeaux pour les
absolument oui oui on peut dire que
c'est plus une
boutique thématique sur la mer qu'une
librairie pure en fait en france il ya
une multitude de librairies qui font
librairie papeterie
moi je fais librairie et choses de la
mer voilà en somme si vous voulez vous
avez un bateau bien sûr henry vous
pensez qu'un jour elle vous quittera la
passion de la mer
non sûrement pas cette passion-là me
quittera sûrement pas non je crois que
ça c'est peut-être même la seule à la
limite j'imagine de ne pas avoir de
d'appartements domicile mais par exemple
depuis avoir deux bateaux me paraît
complètement inconcevable
merci et bertrand de cas des pins et
nous allons maintenant à la maison des
poètes et des écrivains
[Musique]
ah oui ça a beaucoup de charme ce
quartier historique tout est historique
à saint malo mais là c'est un quartier
spécialement historique avec des maisons
qui ont été refaites rénové entretenu
bien comme il faut
mais la plus vieille maison de saint
malo vous ne la connaissez pas encore en
y va tout de suite
[Musique]
que
il ya voilà la plus vieille maison de
saint malo façade en bois et l'a échappé
à deux incendies 1661 et puis le fameux
bombardements de 1944 avec les bombes
incendiaires et leur maintenance est
devenu quoi c'est devenu jeu la maison
international des poètes et des
écrivains et il est animé par une femme
exceptionnelle dodik jégou dodik jégou
ça fait trente ans qu'elle anime des
rencontres internationales de pouvait et
et d'écrivains senghor est venue des
poètes sud-américain très célèbre des
prix nobel sont venus là on va voir
dodik jégo
magnifique votre maison bateau doit
diviser c'est comme ça que vous appelez
bonjour oui c'est un jeu maison bateau
qui a pris son temps voir comment il y a
deux ans maintenant sur ce rocher c'est
la maison international des poètes et
les écrivains
c'est une petite maison trois niveaux
mais il s'y passe des choses formidables
et ozzy recevez les plus grands quoi
l'épurant oui c'est vrai aussi les ce
qu'on aime surtout et qu'on a envie de
partager puisque c'est ça le travail de
cette maison c'est de faire venir les
gens qu'on connaît ou qu'on admire et de
porter cette admiration vers les autres
et de les donner aux autres et puis
beaucoup de poètes parce que c'est je
trouve que ce qui existe vraiment et ce
qui reste dans la littérature et qui
marque tous les pays et toutes les
époques c'est la poésie
oui elle est peu plus mais elle est
polluée on a beaucoup de mal à attirer
les gens quand ce sont les poètes mais
c'est la force du monde et larves
d'ailleurs dans votre prospectus sais
pas si on peut appeler ça comme ça pour
les rencontres internationales de
bretagne 92 est une phrase merveilleuse
quand l'émotion est absente il n'y a
plus qu'un intérêt documentaire la
poésie n'a aucune utilité elle n'est que
nécessaire je trouve ça formidable
tout est dit oui après on n'a plus rien
à dire c'est la vérité
bon le public les malouins là ils
viennent les vip les malouins viennent
de plus en plus et de toutes sortes
aussi bien des gens qui aiment la langue
gallèse où la langue bretonne que ceux
qui aiment les choses plus pointues ou
plus ciblées comme des choses sur
l'histoire etc
et puis les gens viennent de saint
brieuc de dole de dinan de rennes de
normandie du bas de la france si on est
sujet c'est assez extraordinaire ce qui
se passe ici non dépendantes les
malouines sors pas beaucoup de chez eux
oui et beaucoup aussi ils ont cette
image que j'aime bien il regarde
derrière larry
dos mais certains libraires me dise
qu'on vend des livres ce qui se passe
ici pendant la semaine qui a suivi le
passage de l'écrivain donc c'est bon
signe
dodik jégu vous n'êtes pas seulement un
supporters des écrivains et des poètes
internationaux et est breton aussi un
particulier vous êtes vous-même une
artiste une artiste en céramique est
reconnu dans le monde entier
oui reconnu dans le monde entier bon
c'est ce qui est mis dans les journaux
c'est peut-être vrai puisque j'ai des
oeuvres dans le monde entier
mais mon travail de céramistes en fait
étaient eux un travail d'image hier
puisque j'ai illustré depuis des années
tous les grands noms de la littérature
de de cette région qui est donc une
littérature très forte et extraordinaire
magique est magique et c'est justement
cette action culturelle mais cette
rencontre avec des écrivains de tous les
pays vient de là puisque les gens nous
demandaient mais c'est qui qui sont ces
gens que vous illustrez et un jour
l'idée nous est venue donc de faire
connaître les gens de les faire venir
eux-mêmes parler de leurs oeuvres
et c'est comme ça que c'est en boîte et
toute cette histoire du monde entier de
gens qui venaient 10 ans du portugal de
tous les pays
[Musique]
drôle de nostalgie que celle des
terre-neuvas qui font partie de
l'histoire maritime de saint malo et oui
il faut pas oublier que des milliers de
pêcheurs et leurs familles vivaient ici
dans des conditions extrêmement dures au
début du siècle où il y avait jusqu'à 90
bateaux qui faisaient terre-neuve alors
aujourd'hui
bah ya des problèmes dans la morue les
problèmes à saint pierre et miquelon au
canada et problème en norvège des
problèmes de quotas et les bateaux vous
voyez ici
le joseph roty 2 le grande hermine le
victor aps les veines et bien sont à
quai en chômage technique
il reste une centaine de marins sur ces
chalutiers usine surgélateurs de la com
à pêche
il y en avait 4 et y en a un qui s'est
échoué l'année dernière
on va voir avec deux membres d'équipage
comment on vit ici pas oui ce sommet
technique le fait qu'on ne puisse plus
partir en mer
bonjour messieurs merci vous accueillir
à bord du grande hermine michel mensuel
vous êtes second mécanicien et vous pour
le noël réveillère vous êtes vraiment
dur à mandeure c'est quoi un vendeur
c'est une petite équipe de spécialistes
qui répare les chaluts quand il ya des
avaries alors en ce moment vous êtes au
chômage technique
voilà c'est ça oui je mange technique
jusqu'à la fin de l'année le chômage
technique comment est ce que vous le
vivez car les premiers mots nous sommes
pris en charge par l'armement et deux
premiers mois puis après ben c'est comme
tout le monde l assedic et il ya
sûrement beaucoup de chômage dans votre
profession en ce moment dans la nôtre
vis occupe deux équipages c'est pas le
victor et des armées depuis le début de
l'année il apprend d'équipage victor
conte des réparties sur les deux qui
restent comment vous vivez alors vous
fait vivre aux familles car il arrive
que comme la n'avons fiennes dans fait
chaud on a fait de bonnes campagnes juif
ça peut aller pour cette année mais
comme les doigts du victor qui était
suffisant heures au début de l'année ils
sont rentrés avec 80 keaton je crois et
puis depuis ils ont rien eu
comment ils vous payez comment ça marche
contre le bateau pêche à la part de
pêche
c'est suivant le tonnage ramener on les
départs sont très différentes par
exemple un novice aéroports 80 jeunes de
16 ans analystes puis après base suivant
les qualifications quoi que moira
mondiaux s'il part 60 bas après un chef
à mettre des canadiens c'est combien 4
par des différences assez importante ça
a toujours été ça a toujours existé
comme ça énorme at her lui la tombe bien
c'est à dire c'est sur la vente de
terrains il ya un cinquième pour les
équipages et 4/5 pour le
pour l'armateur on peut avoir une idée
de vos revenus respectifs sur une année
si ça fonctionne non il n'ya pas des
lieux peut pas donner sur sur une année
parce que c'est complètement différent
d'une année à l'autre
ça peut du simple au double cette année
ce qu'ils ont fait toute l'année sur la
grande hermine en rogne bonne paye mais
ce brain dernière c'était beaucoup moins
bon est ce que vous avez pensé à une
reconversion ailleurs que dans les
pêches n'ont jamais pourquoi il ya vingt
ans que je fais le métier là j'ai
commencé à 16 ans ont pu tant qu'il y
aura des bateaux affaires turn off sur
ternoise on dit r9 mais même si on veut
en norvège ou au groenland ah ça oui on
oui c'est toujours terre-neuve où les
mecs
pourquoi ici de c'est un métier qui vous
passionne on peut on peut dire ça ou oui
oui toute façon celui à qui ça ne plaît
pas il fait une ou deux campagnes et
puis après c'est terminé c'est possible
de faire ce métier là prend des comptes
vous êtes trois mois sur un bateau comme
ça que des hommes puissent rencontrer un
métier que quand même travaillé 12
heures par jour
donc si on ne l'aimé pas on ne faudrait
pas non non non et le rythme du travail
ces douze heures de travail six order
coups sûrs et six heures de
retrouvailles a world airport
ça fait pas beaucoup et on recommence
comme ça tout le temps
17 heures et 6 heures quand il ya du
marais sent qu'il ya du poisson à quoi
ya pas de poisson s'il ya du matériel à
faire s'il ya des chaluts à réparer on
en profite et puis va autrement bas dans
le télé quand même vous êtes mariés oui
vous avez deux enfants
ouais alors qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'elle
dit votre femme et vos enfants vous êtes
parti combien de temps un mois et demi
quatre mois ça dépend oui enfin
maintenance heureux sur celui-là c'est
surtout un mois et demi deux mois pas ma
femme a dit qu'elle s'y habitue pas que
c'est de plus en plus dur elle vous
invite à changer de métier ou non voilà
essayé au début mai et vous et vous moi
ça fait 23 ans que je suis la compagnie
maintenant géré jusqu'à la retraite
merci messieurs alors on a évoqué au
très rapidement les familles des
terre-neuvas eh bien on va voir
maintenant un extrait d'une récente
émission signé alain gayda
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le jour où j'ai vu ce bateau plongée
nous étions en plein repas de noël
ma fille qui a arrêté de manger moment
c'est pas possible papa lé là en ce
moment et c'est vrai que sal je me
refusais à voir tout ça c'était un refus
de ma part parce que sinon j'aurais vécu
que dans l'anxiété
j'y pensais mais je refuse et je ne
voulais plus je ne voulais plus penser à
tout ça parce que sinon j'allais porter
ma vie devient un enfer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
andré lespagnol j'ai montré tout à
l'heure votre gros livres gros livre
s'appelle messieurs de saint malo est
bon c'est une passion d'universitaires
je suis tombé recherche une dizaine
d'années une bonne on vient de parler
des des terre-neuvas alors ça c'était un
million que vers la participant à la
prospérité de la ville
tout à fait c'est la base même de
l'activité maritime et de la réussite
des premiers marchands donc je crois que
c'est vraiment le socle de ce qui a fait
saint malo pendant des siècles et encore
jusqu'à aujourd'hui vous avez vu la com
à pêche encore qu'elles sont en sommeil
vient sûreté c'est à partir de là que
saint malo s'est développée non
seulement comme ville de marins qu'elle
a toujours été
mais comme ville de marchands et un
certain stade xviie xviiie siècle qui
comme une ville de négociants
c'est-à-dire de grands marchands opérant
à l'échelle internationale est capable
de monter de très grandes affaires dont
on a du mal à se faire une idée
aujourd'hui les capteurs nié par exemple
oui alors il faut dire par exemple que
les malouins qui pratiquaient de longue
date le commerce avec l'amérique
espagnole par le par le biais de
l'espagne par cadix autour de 1700 se
sont lancés dans une aventure
extraordinaire qui est d'atteindre
directement les marchés d'amérique du
sud du pérou mais l'argent des mines du
poteau sic en doublant le cap horn
directement l'ouverture véritable la
route du cap horn même si c'est des
hollandais qui l'ont découvert il l'a
créée dans les années 10 710 720 pour
aller aux sources de l'argent du poteau
syrienne
il fallait être effectivement très
hardie il fallait les gros moyens ainsi
pour équiper des navires dans cette
direction ce que faisaient les
négociants et ils ont retiré pendant 15
ans une source de richesse fabuleuse les
corsaires ça a compté oui il n'ya pas
vraiment que ça moi pour que d'une digue
et 3 1 t1 type vient aussi un officier
est lui aussi un pur initialement à
négocier en tout quatre mois c'est le
sommet de l'activité corsair la course
ne doit pas être séparé de cela la
course est une des formes de l'aventuré
économique
à l'époque de louis xiv un des moyens
aussi d'acquérir la richesse en temps de
guerre
en capturant les navires ennemis au lieu
de pratiquer le commerce pour soi même
mais ça n'est pas d'un ordre différent
c'est aussi une aventure économique la
course en même temps qu'une aventure
maritime
mais n'oublions pas l'aspect économique
est vrai et c'est pour ça qu'on connaît
l'histoire que louis xiv a dit un jour
bon alors bas
je peux beaucoup d'argent avec caisse si
on allait voir ces messieurs de saint
malo oui alors disons que l'emprunt
entre guillemets des malouins à louis
xiv en 1709 au plus profond de la crise
du royaume d'ailleurs a été un emprunt
forcé et soyons clairs néanmoins c'était
ça ou alors pour la vie qu'on fait très
directement ce que louis xiv a saisi
lundi 7-6 9/7 une partie des richesses
de l'argent en métal revenus de la mer
du sud et qui arrive en un convoi massif
à port louis au sud de la péninsule
bretonne porté par des navires malouin
et cette saisie en quelque sort d'une
partie au moins de l'argent ramené de la
mer du sud par les malouins va permettre
au royaume d'éviter la faillite
financière dans une crise au moment de
la guerre de succession d'espagne c'est
d'un épisode historique notable est il à
la gloire des malouins oui et non ils
n'ont pas donné bon de bon coeur leur
argent mais ils ont contribué
effectivement à renflouer les finances
royales
aujourd'hui vous diriez quoi si vous
étiez observateurs ce n'est pas bon vous
diriez quoi aller et bourgeois marchand
capitaliste de l'époque de louis xiv
quand est ce qu'ils ont laissé une
tradition espérons qu'ils ont ravi les
c'est le meilleur de leurs traditions
c'est à dire effectivement l'esprit d'
aventure au bon sens du terme d'
aventure économique l'esprit
d'entreprise l'esprit aussi je pense
d'ouverture sur le monde car autour de
1700 cette cité dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons était une cité qui commerçait à
l'échelle du globe
je crois qu'il faut bien situé et ça
c'est cependant bien l'importance et
vous pensez que penser andré lespagnol
que la piétaille si on peut dire ça des
marins et à ce qu'ils naviguaient qui a
été une des relais courts la réussite
dont ils ont ils ont touché leur part du
gâteau
disons qu'ils sont partis avec l'espoir
eux aussi de décrocher sinon le gros lot
du moins un lot dans l' aventure
quelques-uns ont pu le faire à travers
la course et les parts de prise
les plus chanceux quelques autres en
pratiquant ce qu'on appelait le commerce
de pacotille il apportait quelques
marchandises pour leur compte qu'il
pouvait vendre en amérique du sud ou aux
indes
quelques-uns ont pu effectivement saisir
j'irai quelques miettes de la richesse
qui s'est ici accumulé beaucoup
cependant ils ont surtout laissé la vie
ou la santé dans des voyages au long
cours extrêmement rude avec des taux de
mortalité très fort mais ses matelots de
savalou même et du pays malouin d'une
de recrutement qui allait de saint briac
à cancale qui remontaient l'estuaire de
la rance
on était une des conditions nécessaires
de cette réussite malouines un
commissaire ici de marine du début du
xviiie siècle disait les meilleurs
matelots du monde sans ses matelots
effectivement laventure malouines
n'aurait pas été possible
merci à l'espagnol
[Musique]
daniel gélin raconte le plus populaire
ici en notre jeunesse füle sans conteste
surcouf
non seulement parce qu'il était entré
dans la légende mais parce que ses
descendants vivait et vivent encore
parmi nous et ça nous allons revoir dans
un instant si la fière devise de la
ville ni français ni breton mâle on en
suit convient beaucoup de cancers c'est
peut-être à surcouf qu'elle si lemieux
spectaculaire marin habité de défis et
mélangeant la folie la plus audacieuse
au sens le plus aiguë son intérêt sa vie
entière illustre admirablement le destin
de la france sur les mers pendant la
révolution qui interdit la traite des
noirs
ils la pratiquent a clandestinement
combattit ensuite les anglais en
invincible corsaires de 20 son propre
armateurs recours ça les anglais et
après la chute de l'empiré il devint le
plus riches armateurs de france
alors nous allons voir justement le
dernier cotre qui l'a armé pour la
course en manche et il s'appelle le
renard
ce
bonjour
bonjour robert surcouf général c'est
impressionnant d'appeler quelqu'un
robert sur coutras robert surcouf qu'il
ne doit plus exister grand chose du
pactole que surcouf avait légué mais
vous avez hérité un petit quelque chose
quand même et à cenon un petit peu de
ressemblance on le dit tout au moins et
puis j'ai hérité du nom et du prénom
oui et puis d'un petit d'une petite
propriété aussi oui enfin j'habite une
maison qui a été construit par un des
fils du père serre par adolphe surcouf
qui était un de ses fils bon alors vous
savez que c'est très contestée votre
descendance directe avec robert surcouf
ya même une association des descendants
de surcouf
ab je n'ai jamais eu la prétention de me
présenter comme descendants directs
en fait je suis l'arrière petit-neveu du
père serre je descends du frère cadet
sur tout ce qui s'appelait nicolas est
ce que les gens ignorent c'est qu'il y
avait quatre frères sur pousses de la
même génération
quelques resserre à la mer et paul henri
charles robert nicolas enault niveau là
dans des centres et robert a été le plus
honnêtement il avait le meilleur agent
publicité et c'est lui qui a fait la
meilleure carrière maritime
alors n'y a pas vraiment de conflit
entre les descendants de surcouf et et
vous même un peu un peu un peu pourquoi
ben en fait parce que dans la branche
direct des descendants directs de robert
surcouf le nom est perdu ils ont fait
des filles
il n'y a que dans notre branche où on a
dardé non parce qu'on l'a fait les
garçons prennent volontairement
peut-être m'enfin ils sont là et moi
même j'ai trois fils et j'espère que non
et entend perpétuer pour de nombreuses
générations alors vous nous rappeler le
surcoût venons vous dites être le
descendant
non nicolas noël nicole frère cadet qui
étaient à bord de la confiance lors de
l'happy du cac
petite goutte non sous les ordres de son
frère sur le revenant quelques années
plus tard merci de cette précision
mais pourquoi cette polémique que face à
ces reports à grand chose avait pas de
mon fait grand chose
enfin ça arrive merci robert surcouf et
on va les voir un autre descendante
surcouf arles histoire de famille ça
passionne toujours la france a pris
bonjour patrick font m
bonjour alors vous êtes président de
l'association des descendants de robert
surcouf le corps c'est exact or nous
venons de voir un robert surcouf qui lui
est descendant d'un frère de robert
surcouf le corsaire c'est exact parce
que dans la famille surcouf à l'heure
actuelle il n'y a aucun descendant
direct de robert surcouf avec le nom de
surcouf way dans une descente que d'un
frère de robersart c'est ça il prétend
pas le contraire des noms devront nous
sommes cousins nos cousines ont bien
comme la botte de retard ouais alors il
dit qu'il ya une polémique et que c'est
dommage disons qu une polémique à partir
du moment où il se fait entendre
où il écrit il se faire enregistrer
comme et en descendant direct de robert
surcouf le corset ah oui mais c'est
parce qu'il nous dit à la caméra
alors oui mais à partir du moment où
s'annonce descendant direct de revers se
retrouve ça peut être son grand-père
comme aux travailleuses
j'espère que vous suivez alors le vrae
robert surcouf le vrai robert surcouf de
saint malo c'est celui qu'a vécu de 1773
à 1827 et et le sol et à combien ce
qu'on peut estimer la fortune de robert
surcouf
je l'avais estimé il ya quelques temps 2
milliards de francs aux 2 milliards
or ça fait beaucoup sa vie sans
présenterez combien aujourd'hui j'ai pas
d'idée écoutez ça peut représenter
puisque j'ai des documents qui prouvent
que surcouf avait des propriétés du côté
de dole du coup d'être combourg du côté
de quatre villes en normandie est
évidemment à l'île maurice mais alors
simplement pour vous donner une idée
quand surcouf a pris la sybille qui est
un gros bateau je crois que je ne veux
pas me tromper il y avait 38 ou 40 canon
sa prise était estimé à 2 millions de
francs heures donc simplement un bateau
un vaisseau à vaisseau de millions de
francs tôt c'est énorme déjà son écoute
faire la course il a fait 47 prises
combien de vous de vrais descendants de
corsair à l'heure actuelle pour l'année
prochaine j'ai répertorié déjà 70
membres se sont dirigés je pense arriver
au bout de deux ans trois ans parce que
il ya tout un travail de recherche un
travail de généalogie et puis a
travaillé des sommes une association
jeune qui débute on est il faut
absolument plus en voyant le courrier
donc nous faisons appel à toutes les
bonnes volontés il y en aura il croise
en y en a 10 ans avec les enfants les
petits-enfants effectivement parce que
ça fait trois générations
mettez sur les affaires avec ça alors
avec cette association au départ c'était
prévu que ce soit une association
familiale
eh bien non c'est pas ce qu'il va se
passer ça va être en fin de compte une
association qui va conserver le socle le
souvenir de regard sur tout le corps
sert keira éviter ou empêcher que l'on
donne le nom de robert surcouf les soirs
prix commercialement à sa disparation ce
qui se passe à l'heure actuelle
conserver également en plus le souvenir
l'esprit mais tout ça c'est un tout bon
mais et skieurs vraiment encore un
descendant de robert surcouf qui
s'appellerait robert surcouf alors
normalement je n'avais pas l'intention
d'en parler mais je veux vous faire une
révélation
c'est que un descendant du baron antoine
surcouf existe il habite new york et
j'espère avoir le plaisir de
l'accueillir à la municipalité de saint
malo au 15 août
en 93
attendez je me perds en traîne surcouf
le bar en automne sur pc par robert
surcouf de parrot antoine se retrouvent
qui est décédé il ya quatre cinq ans ni
date en tête était le dernier descendant
mâle de robert surcouf le corsaire et il
arriva le petit fils qui s'appelle
robert surcouf par conséquent c'est le
vrai et le seul robert surcouf qui
existent descendant par les mâles il est
américain
merci le prix de fournels
[Musique]
parmis tant d'illustrés personnages qui
partir de saint malo pour courir le
monde
bille ou bien sur chateaubriand françois
rené il naquit rue des juifs le 4
septembre 1768 à l'hôtel de la gigue et
les deux là gicquel est ce qui me
retourne complètement on l'imaginé il
décrit son enfance à la fois mystique et
bagarreuse dans ses mémoires
d'outre-tombe et à 10 ans il dit que les
polissons de la ville étaient devenus
ses plus chers amis il adorait jouer sur
les remparts avec les vagues des
tempêtes lui aussi et ça se passait
justement là là au pied de la tour
pourquoi la partie saint malo n'est
qu'un rocher disait-il aux prêts au loin
sont semées d'autres roches et d'efforts
des îlots inhabités le fort royal la
conchée cézembre et le grand baie où
sera mon tombeau j'avais bien choisis
sans le savoir b en breton cela
signifique tombe et châteaubriant
expliquent les habitants de saint malo
s'adresser à moi le 25 août 1828 par
l'entremise de leur mère au sujet d'un
bassin flou qu'il désirait établir
je m'empressais de répondre sollicitant
en échange de bienveillance une
concession de quelques pieds de terre
pour mon tombeau sur le grand baie seul
à souffrir des difficultés à cause de
l'opposition du génie militaire mais
finalement chateaubriand again cause
puisque il sut qu'il aurait son tombeau
au grand baie 17 ans avant sa voix alors
chateaubriand devait être prêt tout
marin il demain finalement un grand
écrivain et un homme politique et il
parcouru l'amérique l'europe et l'orient
en véritable malouin qui n'était
finalement
et puis j'aime assez cette citation de
châteaubriant en 1846 je suis né
gentilhomme l'aristocratie dont la
dernière heure dont la dernière heure a
sonné à trois âges successifs l'âge des
supériorités l'âge des privilèges et
l'âge des vanités sortie du premier elle
dégénère dans le second et settat dans
le dernier mais c'est valable pour tout
le monde tout le monde c'est un dans la
vanité finalement
[Musique]
m
oui
[Musique]
cool
il
[Musique]
i
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et les
parmi les curiosités maritime ici à
saint malo il ya une petite activité
touristique qui se porte bien d'ailleurs
ce sont les chercheurs
alors on loue des bateaux pour un
dimanche pour un week-end pour des
croisières d'ailleurs pas forcément au
karim mais en mer dinars et ce sont des
charters bas sur sur un bateau de
surcouf ou bien sûr le pen bucsis de
tabarly et c'est valérie york elle est
allée voir
[Musique]
ils nous ont paradé cet été à brest 92
les vieux gréements font maintenant pris
leurs quartiers d'hiver dont leur corps
d'origine
aujourd'hui la part à déterminer et
comme il faut bien gagner sa vie il me
doit ce loup et le renard ce cotre
corsaire réplique du dernier bateau de
surcouf proposera dès le printemps
prochain à tous les amateurs des
journées en mer balade à travers les
îles et à travers l'histoire que nous
embarquons des groupes ou des personnes
du sur le plan individuel
particulièrement l'été entre juillet et
août bien sûr dans les intersaisons
printemps et automne c'est plutôt la
sphère des groupes genre comité
d'entreprise que la sortie de passes
colère des choses comme ça kelly confort
à barres c'est le confort il est à peu
près celui que le bateau d'origine au
frais tu peux dire c'est plus de choses
mais les gens ne viennent pas ici pour
trouver des cabines avec des toilettes
et des salles de bain ils viennent parce
que ils veulent se retremper dans
l'histoire
une journée sur le renard vous coûtera
entre 100 et 300 francs par personne
selon la saison mais le renard n'est pas
seule à offrir des promenades à tous
ceux qui le souhaitent
son voisin de quais l'étoile molène un
ancien thonier ne désarmera pas de
l'hiver à côté d'eux un autre rêve le
pen louis xi l'ancien bateau de tabarre
n'y est pas comme l'ex critères 5 de
malinowski sont eux aussi offerts à la
location soit pour un jour soit pour des
croisières plus lointaines
[Musique]
ça fait rêver les gens un petit peu
embarqués sur des bateaux avec des noms
comme fenwick ou pas comme et puis sur
les vieux gréements
bah c'est vrai que ça les ramène un
petit peu dans le passé sont des bateaux
qui sont toujours loué avec un équipage
absolument les ces bateaux là de par
leur taille sont systématiquement loué
avec l'équipage et en fonction de leur
taille
il ya donc un patron et dans certains
cas donc un patron et un match où on
peut louer pen duick 6 pour combien
globalement c'est de six à douze mille
francs par jour et la base c'est 14
personnes
[Musique]
en quittant sa malo et le souvenir de
ces malouin qui ont fait en mer sa
fortune est la leur je ne peux pas ne
pas imaginer la rude vie des simples
matelots d'équipage qui poursuivent
vaille que vaille la tradition des
terre-neuvas et en attendant que les
gros chalutiers de la com à pêche
repartent en campagne c'est surtout à
ses matelots que je pense bon vent à
vous les vrais messieurs de saint malo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
et
d
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en quittant sa maman je comprends mieux
daniel gélin je peux ressenti ça aussi
d'ailleurs je suis venu en ces endroits
souvent pour mme agrandir le regard et
l'âme me nettoyer des doutes et des
questions difficiles les lassitudes et
chagrin les effrois j étais non
seulement ragaillardi console et
purifier mais aussi animé d'un amour
énorme pour tous les êtres du monde pour
tous les peuples les races avec leurs
sites et leurs histoires leurs valeurs
et leur âme collective samedi prochain
nous serons à brest une autre ville d'
aventure et vous verrez une aventure
très moderne à samedi
[Musique]